[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning we have
some historic breaking news at this hour
nasa has just achieved a liftoff on mars
unlike any other
in history so take a look at this it's a
little bit hard to see but that right
there
is a robot called ingenuity
taking its first flight on mars that
small flight is in fact a giant leap for
humanity because it is the first
controlled aircraft flight
ever under its own power to fly on
another planet
think about that john the vigliotti is
at nasa's jet propulsion laboratory
in pasadena california jonathan good
morning to you it was only 120 years ago
that we had our first flight period on
any planet now we're on another one
pretty amazing achievement what's nasa
doing to celebrate
yeah tony what's 120 years a massive
celebration inside mission control as
you can imagine behind me this morning
engineers celebrating the seemingly
impossible they had to create a robot
that was self-flying
and self-powered with an engine five
times faster than
any helicopter here on earth and all of
that technology had to fit into a
container get this the size of a tissue
box this test flight only lasted a few
seconds
but a major victory this morning for
nasa
at just about 19 inches tall and 4
pounds
nasa's ingenuity helicopter is tiny in
size
but its impact could be monumental we
could use it to
do reconnaissance and scope out where
the path we'd like to take with a rover
or if we're sending humans to mars
helping the humans in their activities
so
there's really an enormous amount of
potential for this capability
lori glaze is director of nasa's
planetary science division
nasa researchers spent six years
perfecting
how to get this self-flying device to
climb about
10 feet above the surface of mars hover
in place for
30 seconds then rotate before gently
making its landing
it's a challenging mission especially on
mars where the air is
so thin glaze says it's the equivalent
of flying at an altitude of one hundred
thousand feet on earth it's almost three
times
as high as a commercial aircraft flies
we don't fly up there
there's not enough air to give you lift
under the wings and so
trying to get your helicopter to fly in
that environment
is really really hard it's so hard that
ingenuity's made in flight was actually
delayed earlier this month
after a software glitch during a
pre-flight test
since then the device has passed several
tests including a critical spin check of
its four rotors last week
she was deployed the nearly 85 million
dollar helicopter arrived on mars
in february about 20 meters off the
surface attached to the belly of nasa's
perseverance rover
that's unconfirmed i
truly fundamentally believe that
ingenuity alone
you know can't make things happen you
really need ingenuity plus
that perseverance the very hard work to
make
you know a great idea a reality neiman
is the project manager for ingenuity
ingenuity is up in the air you're
looking on what's going on in your mind
i think i'll probably celebrate for the
first time then
i think that we did it you know we did
it i think all those
hours all those weekends and i mean just
months of testing and designing
different phases i think this is what
drove us
it's our dream come true
and mimi had her fists up in the air in
that control room as she was waiting for
that data to come back history made
170 million miles away and people in
this neighborhood came out to shout in
celebration
ingenuity will have longer flights over
the coming weeks all this
as nasa continues their search for signs
of life
on mars gail again the size of a tissue
box
i know it struck me when you said that
jonathan thank you good to see you
it's good to see you it's it's it's
really fascinating when
it's it's really good to hear rather
when all your hard work pays off when
she says working all those weekends
working all those late nights and then
it goes
what the way you extraordinary
achievement i mean thank you
what an extraordinary achievement that
they've done a whirled away
i i you know you worry it's a little
teeny video it's a little rainy it's
hard to see
it is a very big deal and i'm glad to
hear that people in that neighborhood
there in pasadena california actually
came out and cheered
while jonathan was there in the dark in
the early hours in california
i'm glad you pointed it out because i'm
looking at this being like what where is
it
nicely done nasa nicely done